so some breaking news in the last few
minutes uh boris johnson has now
publicly commented on last night's
arrests at the sarah everard vigil so
let's go live to westminster our
political correspondent tom rayner is
there for us
so tom what's the prime minister said
yes well this is part of downing street
confirming that the prime minister will
chair a meeting
of the crime and justice task force
tomorrow focusing
on violence against women and girls and
as part of that we have had a statement
from boris johnson which is the first
we have heard his first reaction since
those events took place last night let
me read it to you
it says like everyone who saw it i was
deeply concerned about the footage from
clapham common on saturday night
i have spoken with the metropolitan
police commissioner who has committed to
reviewing how this was handled
and the home secretary has also
commissioned her majesty's inspectorate
of constabulary
to conduct a lessons learned review into
the policing of the event
the death of sarah everard must unite us
in determination to drive out violence
against women and girls
and make every part of the criminal
justice system work
to protect and defend them well in this
note from downing street we also
are told that the agenda for that
meeting will include looking at some of
the
53 000 responses that the government has
had since
friday when it reopened its consultation
on its strategy
for violence against girls and women
also looking at plans to for safer
streets whether more can be done with
regards to cctv
and street lighting to make people feel
better protected and
a look at the government's ongoing
review into great prosecutions in the
criminal justice system
looking at whether more can be done to
bring perpetrators to justice
and indeed to support victims
interestingly anna
the makeup of that task force is the
prime minister the home secretary the
justice secretary the director of public
prosecutions
and the met commissioner christopher
dick who
this evening of course confirmed that
she was not considering her position
despite the pressure she has come under